just uh a decade or so before in in 1950
alan turing
wrote the paper that formulated the
touring test and he opened that paper
with the question
can machines
so let me ask you this question can
machines
think can your ice cube tray
one day think
um certainly machines can think because
i believe you're a machine and i'm a
machine and i believe we both think um i
think it's a big fear i think any other
philosophical position is sort of a
little ludicrous what does think mean if
if it's not something that we do
um and we and we are machines um
so yes machines can but do we have a
clue how to build such machines that's a
very different question are we capable
of building such machines uh you know
are we smart enough we think we're smart
enough to do anything but
maybe we're not maybe you know we're
just not smart enough to build
it's not like us the kind of computer
that alan turing was thinking about do
you think there is something
fundamentally
uh or significantly different between
the computer between our ears the the
biological computer that humans use and
uh the computer that he was thinking
about from a from a sort of high level
philosophical yeah i believe it uh that
it's very wrong in fact i'm
halfway through a
i think it'll be about a 480 page book
um
titled the working title is not even
wrong
and if i may i'll tell you a bit about
that
so there's two two well three thrusts to
it
um
one is the history of computation what
we call computation
goes all the way back to uh
some manuscripts in latin from 1614 and
1620 by napier and kepler through
babbage and lovelace and then
turing's 1936 paper uh is you know what
we think of as the invention of of of
modern computation
and that paper by the way did not set
out to
you know invent computation it set out
to
negatively answer one of uh hilbert's
three later set of problems he called it
um
as an effective way of of getting
answers and and hilbert
hilbert really worked with rewriting
rules as did um
um
a church who also at the same time a
month earlier in turing disproved
hilbert's one of these three hypotheses
the other two had been already been
disproved by godel so turing set out to
disprove it because that's it's always
easier to disprove these things than to
prove that there is an answer
and um
so he needed um
and it really came from his his uh
professor well as an undergrad at
cambridge who said who turned it into is
there a mechanical process so he wanted
to have a show a mechanical process that
could calculate numbers
because that was a mechanical process
that people used to generate tables they
were called computers the people at the
time and they followed a set of rules
where they had paper and they would
write numbers down and based on the
numbers to keep writing other numbers
and they would produce
numbers for these tables engineering
tables
that the more the more iterations they
did the more significant digits came out
and so turing
in that paper set out to
define what sort of machine could do
that mechanical machine
where it could produce an arbitrary
number of digits in the same way a human
computer did
and he came up with a very simple
set of constraints where there was an an
infinite supply of paper
the tape of the turing machine
and each turing machine had a
set i mean came with a set of
instructions that
as a person could do with pencil and
paper write down things on the tape and
erase them and put new things there
and
he was able to show that that system was
not able to do something that hilbert
hypothesized so he disproved it but he
had to show this was this this system
was
good enough to do
whatever could be done but couldn't do
this other thing yeah and there he said
and he says in the paper i don't have
any real arguments for this but based on
intuition
so that's how he defined computation
and then if you look over the next from
1936 up until really around 1975
you see people struggling with
is this really what computation is
and so marvin minsky very well known in
ai but also a fantastic mathematician
uh in his book finite and infinite
machines from the mid-60s which is a
beautiful beautiful mathematical book
says says at the start of the book well
what is computation turing says it's
this and yeah i sort of think it's that
it doesn't really matter whether stuff's
made of wood or plastic it's just you
know that relatively cheap stuff can do
this stuff and so yeah
seems like computation
and donald knuth uh in his first volume
of his
you know art of computer programming
in around 1968
says well what's computation
it's this stuff like turing says that a
person could do each step without too
much trouble
and so one of his examples of what would
be too much trouble was
a step which required knowing
whether fermat's last theorem was true
or not because it was not known at the
time and that's too much trouble for a
person to do as a step
and um
hopcraft and ullman
sort of said a similar thing
later that year and by 1975
in the ajo up craft the norman book
they're saying
well you know we don't really know what
computation is but intuition says this
is sort of about right and this is what
it is
that's computation it's a sort of
agreed upon thing which happens to be
really easy to implement in silicon and
then we had moore's law which took off
and it's been an incredibly powerful
tool
i certainly wouldn't argue with that the
version we have a computation incredibly
powerful
can we just take a pause so what we're
talking about is there's an infinite
tape with some simple rules on how to
write and on that tape and that's that's
what we're kind of thinking about this
is computation yeah and it's modeled
after humans how humans do stuff and
i think it's a
turing says in the 36 paper one of the
critical facts here is that a human has
a limited amount of memory
so that's what we're going to put onto
our
mechanical computers
so
so you know unlike mass
i'm like mass or charge or yeah it's not
it's it's not given by the universe it
was
this is what we're going to call
computation yeah and then it has this
really uh you know it had this really
good implementation which has completely
changed our technological world that's
computation
second part of the book
i or
argument book i have this two by two
matrix with
um science
in the top row
engineering the bottom row
left column is intelligence right column
is life
so in the bottom row the engineering
there's artificial intelligence and
there's artificial life
in the top row there's neuroscience
and abiogenesis how does living matter
turn in how does non-living matter
become living better yes four
disciplines these four disciplines all
um
came into the current form in the period
1945 to 1965.
um
that's interesting there was
neuroscience before but it wasn't
effective neuroscience it was you know
these ganglia and there's electrical
charges but no one knows what to do with
it
and furthermore
there are a lot of players who are
common across them
i've
identified common players except for
artificial intelligence and habiogenesis
i don't have but for any other pair i
can point to people who work them and a
whole bunch of them by the way were at
the research lab for electronics at mit
um where uh warren mcculloch uh held
held held forth
and in fact mcculloch pitts um latvian
and maturana wrote the first paper on
functional neuroscience called what the
frog's eye tells the frog's brain where
instead of it just being this bunch of
nerves they sort of showed what
different
anatomical components were doing and
telling other anatomical components
and
you know generating behavior in the
front would you put them as basically
the fathers or the one of the early
pioneers of what are now called
artificial neural networks
yeah i mean mcculloch and pitts uh
pitts was a was much younger than him in
1943 had written a paper inspired by
bertrand russell
on a calculus for the ideas eminent in
neural
systems
where they had tried to without any real
proof
they had tried to give a formalism for
neurons
basically in terms of logic and gates or
gates and not gates with no
real
evidence that that was what was going on
but they they talked about it and that
that was picked up by minsky for his
uh dissertation on which was a was a
neural network we would call it today
it was picked up by um
john von neumann when he was designing
the edback computer in 1945 he talked
about its components being neurons um
based on and in references he's only got
three references and one of them is the
mcculloch pitts paper
so all these people and then the ai
people and the artificial live people
which was john von neumann originally it
was like overlap as you know they're all
going around the same time and three of
these four disciplines turn to
computation as their primary metaphor
so i i've got a couple of chapters in
the book one is titled wait
computers are people because that's
where our computers came from yeah
and you know from people who are
computing stuff and then i've got
another chapter
wait people are computers which is about
computational neuroscience yes so
there's this whole circle here
and that computation is it and you know
i have talked to to people about well
maybe it's not computation that goes on
in the head of course it is yeah okay
well
when elon musk's rocket goes up is it
computing
is that how it gets into orbit by
but we've got this idea if you want to
build an ai system you write a computer
program
yeah in a sense so the word computation
very quickly starts doing a lot of work
that it was not initially intended to to
do it's the second saying if you talk
about the universe as essentially
performing a computation yeah right
wolfram does this he turns it into
computation
you don't turn rockets into computation
yeah by the way when you say computation
in our conversation do you tend to think
of computation narrowly in the way
touring thought of computation
it's it's it's gotten very
okay
you know
squishy yeah squishy okay
um
but
computation in the way turing thinks
about it and the way most people think
about it
actually fits very well with um
thinking like a hunter-gatherer
there are places and there can be stuff
in places and the stuff in places can
change and it stays there until someone
changes it
and it's this
metaphor of place and container which
you know is a combination of our
place cells in our hippocampus and uh
cortex
but this is this is how we use metaphors
for mostly to think about and when we
get outside of our metaphor range we
have to invent tools which we can sort
of switch on to use so calculus is an
example of a tool it can do stuff that
our raw reasoning can't do and we've got
conventions of when you can use it or
not
but sometimes um
you know people try to
all the time we always try to get
physical metaphors for things which is
why
quantum mechanics has been such a
problem for a hundred years because it's
a particle no it's a wave it's got to be
something we understand and i say no
it's some weird mathematical logic
that's different from those but we want
that metaphor
well you know i i suspect that that you
know 100 years or 200 years from now
neither quantum mechanics nor nor dark
matter will be talked about in the same
terms you know in the same way that um
lodges theory eventually went away um
because
it wasn't an adequate explanatory
metaphor you know that metaphor was the
stuff
there is stuff in
the burning the burning is in the matter
because it turns out the burning was
outside the matter it was the oxygen
so our desire for metaphor and combined
with our limited cognitive capabilities
gets us into trouble that's my argument
in this book now and people say well
what is it then and i say well i wish i
knew that i tried to talk about that but
i you know give some ideas but so so
there's the three things computation is
sort of a particular thing we use
um
uh
oh can i tell you one beautiful thing
one passing of him so you know i used an
example of a thing that's different from
computation you hit a drum and it
vibrates and there are some some
stationary points on the drum surface
you know because the waves are going up
and down the stationary points
now
you could compute them
to arbitrary precision um but the drum
just knows them the drum doesn't have to
compute
what was the very first computer program
ever written by ada lovelace
to compute bernoulli numbers and the
newly numbers are exactly what you need
to find those stable points in the drum
surface wow anyway and there was a bug
in her program
the arguments to divide were reversed in
one place
and it still worked well she never got
to run it they never built the
analytical engines you wrote the program
without without it you know
uh so uh so computation computation is
sort of you know a thing that's
become dominant as a metaphor but yeah
is it the right metaphor um
all three of these four fields adopted
computation and
you know the
a lot of it swirls around warren
mcculloch and his all his students and
he
funded a lot of people
and
and and our human metaphors our
limitations to human thinking play into
this
you